what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to have a conversation about black
bolt because word has reached my ears
that apparently people on social media
just general moviegoers are all kind of
warming up to the idea of the inhumans
they're like hey we'd like to see a
little more of the inhumans you know
surely there's got to be more to the
character of black bolt than what we saw
in multiverse of madness
nope wrong black bolt sucks that guy's
always sucked and he he sucks the most
out of all the inhumans medusa is kind
of cool sometimes i guess but like with
all the inhumans they suck man they're
not interesting at all so here's the
thing about black bull right and i'm
just gonna i'm just going in right i'm
just i'm just going in what you saw in
that movie that's that is a perfect
representation of black bolt in the
comics an idiot right like his mouth
gets taken away and like his quasi-sonic
scream is this power so he's like you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna yell
and
what's the worst that could happen well
i don't know black bolt you big dummy
like your head explodes like that's
normal man like that's that's not an
exception what you saw in multiverse of
madness is not an exception to the rule
it's not like they changed his character
up and made him less interesting for the
film no that's business as usual man
literally the power of black bolt it's
not a quasi-sonic scream it's getting
them cheeks clapped that's the number
one power of black bolt of the inhumans
this guy's only ever been cool twice and
i'll talk about those here in a minute
because i guess i have to talk about all
right here's some here's perfect
examples of black bolt absolutely just
getting just getting clapped and i don't
even mean like he puts up a fight no i
mean like he gets wrecked because he
sucks so the first one is in world war
hulk and i know a lot of you guys are
probably talking about this now i get
what a lot of you guys are saying well
it's world war hulk rob it's the
incredible hulk of the strongest so
i don't care like here's the thing man
like black bolt never stood a chance
those guys who don't know this story
right the illuminati had this genius
idea right in their infinite wisdom when
black panther told them do not do this
it's a terrible idea you're gonna piss
off the hulk it's it's
it was crazy right so like literally
they they their idea is to send the
incredible hulk to like a world where he
could live in peace he ends up flying
into a gravity well and ends up on this
war-torn planet where he basically helps
to overthrow the king and then he gets
like a kind of peaceful life banging
this chick named kaira he gets her
knocked up and then like the ship
explodes and it kills everybody but him
let me tell you something man this dude
was incensed like this guy goes flying
back to earth with his with his warband
so i guess they're the only ones that
survive but like korg and those guys he
goes flying back to earth as pissed off
as he's ever been in his life and he
like the first place he stops is the
moon because the inhuman sucks so bad
nobody wanted them on earth and the
incredible hulk shows up and like black
bolts like oh i'll handle this so he
comes out there and like there's some
kind of an exchange of words and the
incredible hulk's like dude i don't want
to hear you talk man i want to hear you
scream and just like wow just like tears
into this guy he didn't have dude it's
after that man it's just it's an
absolute bloodbath right one war hulk
had some of the most insane moments ever
in the incredible hulk's history it was
absolutely nuts he goes showing up at
the xavier institute after like the
whole house of m events so like 98
percent of the mutant population is gone
and the x-men are like well i guess we
need to step up and try to fight the
incredible hulk who's the strongest he's
ever been and on a pretty rough day when
they run out of his favorite snacks he's
hard to deal with now we got to deal
with this incredible hulk when the
illuminati literally killed his family
so like
let's see how this goes and it doesn't
go well let me tell you something man it
was it was they were not prepared the
incredible hulk comes running in right
like literally shows up on the doorstep
of this place and it's like bring me
xavier or you're all gonna die and so
like literally they they come out right
and like colossus steps up let me tell
you something colossus is he's got the
osmium skin right he's all his osmium
metal form dude warbreaker hulk snaps
his arms in half and it's just like next
and like juggernaut comes running up and
because of plot like literally he just
like diverts the direction of the
juggernaut into like a different
direction because he can't like stop
kane marco dead in his tracks for
reasons that will never make sense
because he was able to do it way back in
the peter david days when he was a
horseman of apocalypse i don't know why
he couldn't do it then but nonetheless
it's just one of those it's that that
going off on a tirade a little bit
that's an example of black bolt getting
those cheeks clocked but the single
greatest moment of black bolt just
absolutely getting smacked around single
greatest moment jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers one son
infinity song son man
man look here's the thing man it was it
was hilarious it was the funniest thing
ever so so so here's what happens right
so the first time you meet like corvus
glaive proxima midnight like super was
it super giant or black dwarf or
whatever it is all those different guys
the first time you meet them they're
traveling around from world of world and
like corvus glaive just like he shows up
on earth to like meet the inhumans and
he immediately starts talking sh to
black bull right he was like i came here
looking for a great king uh can anybody
tell me where i can find one because all
i see is a small king a tiny little king
a king of an insignificant kingdom and
i'm like you're damn right corvus glaive
no one cares about the inhumans the
inhumans don't even care about the
inhumans literally when the terrorism
bomb went off no one wanted to join the
inhuman royal family but unless that's
that's that's we'll talk about that here
in a second so the whole thing about
this is that like basically thanos is
looking for his son and so he sends like
corvus glaive and all those people to
basically bring the heads of all the
firstborn sons right like all the sons
in a certain age range basically
guaranteeing like any son that he had
would basically be dead killed off by
their own race so basically like the
inhumans of course medusa speaks for
black bull the inhumans are just like no
like go go tell your your master
whatever it is we're not dealing with
this or any of that kind of stuff so
then here he comes right thanos comes
walking in now as soon as he comes
walking in there it's just black boat
waiting on him right like like like he's
gonna do anything so literally just
black bolt waiting on him and like a
fight breaks out between the two of them
and i use the term fight loosely because
it's basically just black bolt getting
smacked around and like thanos asking
him questions that's literally what it
is it's basically a police interrogation
from new york city right just like
just getting beat up and asked questions
so so there comes a point when black
bolt screams in the face of thanos right
and we're not talking about black bull
just like talking right like what you
saw in doctor strange multiverse of
madness where he kind of lets off his
power a little bit no i mean like he
lets the full force of his power out and
in one of the greatest moments ever in
the history of comics thanos is just
like enough and he like grabs his mouth
and like just shuts black bolt up and he
was like keep your secrets carry them
with you to the grind like smashes his
head down into the ground and it's just
like yeah man because black bolt sucks
he got a dude he got absolutely crushed
so those are the guys out there who are
watching doctor strange too and who were
like black one of the inhumans seems
kind of cool i'd be interested in seeing
more of him sure there's got to be more
than what i saw in this movie when he
literally got clapped like five minutes
after appearing no that's black bull
like literally the guy is a punching bag
like that's black bolt that that's him
in the comics you ever want to see like
a direct character adaptation from the
comics you saw it when he died not even
10 seconds in to a fight with the
scarlet witch like that's normal man
that's regular that's him reed would
have survived a little bit longer
because he was kind of an idiot in terms
of how he like directly confronted a
woman who's stormy who's literally
reached karen level 99 and is storming
the multiverse because the manager of
the mystic arts wouldn't answer her
question like that's that's
reid would have would have been like
okay so like we should probably go
somewhere else that's not here and like
regroup maybe grab like the x-men who
obviously exist in this world because
xavier's there uh and then like
see if we can beat her right like reid
wouldn't just run in and die but
nonetheless right it's just it's it's
that's that's normally black well now
there have been like two times in his
entire publication history when black
bolt was relevant in any way and the
first one was during house of m when he
basically fought apocalypse and not
really apocalypse is like this guy with
celestial technologies like i mean he's
a horse right like just to give you guys
perspective during the old peter david
run there was a point where apocalypse
literally captured the incredible hulk
and the incredible hulk could not escape
his grass he's literally like holding
him in place right with like his his
tentacle things coming out of his arm
he's like holding him by the mouth and
like holding him it's it's beast right
and then like he turns him into a
horseman so like apocalypse was able to
overpower the incredible hulk and that's
just physical strength you're talking
about a guy that can make himself like 2
000 feet tall they can give himself any
superhuman power with the exception of
reality warping and time travel the guy
can do virtually anything right he's
like a one-man army when that guy shows
up ready to cause some problems things
are gonna pop off right like everybody's
gonna have a bad day and so so in the
the house event storyline there's a
point where like apocalypse goes to
confront
somebody i can't remember who it is but
black bolts there and he just like
whispers and just annihilates apocalypse
and like this huge section of the area
and like that's it right and then the
other part was during the war of kings
when he was basically fighting vulcan
who was an omega level mutant the
brother of cyclops that nobody knew
about there's there's a really really
cool moment in the in the x-men comics
when cyclops fires his object blasts at
vulcan and vulcan sticks his hands up
and or sticks his hand up and like the
object blast goes around vulcan and back
to cyclops it's so cool he's able to
control energy and stuff like that but
like the two of them get into a fight
and they literally rip a hole in space
that turns out leads to the cancer verse
so like those are like the two times
when black bolt was relevant but no in
terms of like is black bald interesting
no he's never been interesting and he
never will be interesting black bolt
sucks he's always sucked right he's
never he's he's like the anchovies of
the superhero community they exist but
nobody wants them so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end a little perspective on the
character of black bolt and the inhumans
do not believe by any standard of
measurement that the inhumans will be as
interesting as the x-men i promise you
they will not there's nothing the mcu
can do to make the inhumans interesting
it's never going to happen so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace